si vous suivez l'actualité vous savez
que samsung a complètement révolutionné
son milieu de gamme et son entrée de
gamme avec des produits complètement
différent la gabegie est morte en voir
la gabegie bonjour la gamme a donc on a
une grande déclinaison au niveau de la
gamma est le premier modèle de la gamme
à avoir été annoncé c'est le samsung
galaxy à 50 c'est lui il est là il est
beau il échoue alors aujourd'hui je vais
faire un unboxing du samsung galaxy à 50
je vais pas le faire sur tous les
modèles je veux que ça soit celui là
pour deux raisons principales la toute
première raison c'est pour voir un petit
peu qu est ce qu a fait samsung au
niveau de son packaging sur cette
nouvelle gamme a alors je ne pense pas
que ce soit un truc complètement ouf
mais c'est pour ça quand même assez
intéressant donc là on a un modèle qui
est complètement si vous voyez bien
fermer la voyez hein j'ai encore la
petite bande de garantie donc on va
l'ouvrir ensemble pour la toute première
fois ce smartphone regarder comment il
fait la boîte on va l'allumer et puis on
va s'en arrêter là et dans quelques
jours je vous sortirez mon test complet
de ce smartphone
alors j'ai déjà vu je déjà pris en main
si vous en souvenez on l'a vu il ya
quelques temps à paris dans de sa
présentation officielle
donc ça c'est la première raison pour
laquelle je vous présentais la deuxième
raison c'est qu'il ya quelques jours je
vous ai fait une vidéo vous demandant
votre avis sur l'évolution de la chaîne
qu'est ce que vous voulez ce train de
bosser sur la rentrée de septembre où
vous demande qu'est ce qui vous ferait
plaisir qu'est ce que vous souhaiteriez
quels sont les points positifs les
points négatifs d'ailleurs ça vous
intéresse vous habite toujours aller
voir cette vidéo comme ça on peut
compléter la discussion et dans les
nombreux retours que j'ai pu le voir
d'ailleurs vous en remercie parce qu'il
prend de retour et c'est vraiment bien
ça me permets moi d'avoir ce vrai
feedback enfin c'est pas le c'est pas le
sujet du jour on m'a dit tiens monsieur
greu est ce que tu pourrais faire plus
de nuke singh alors je me suis dit tiens
pourquoi pas ça un sens je vous invitais
dès maintenant à me dire ce que vous en
pensez en bar aux commentaires de ce
modèle est ce qui peut vous tentez oui
mais quand comment et surtout un dessin
jolie pouces
[Musique]
avant de vous parler du samsung galaxy r
50 vous parler d'autre chose vous parlez
d'un réseau social que je trouve
intéressant ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
change de lurons change d'endroit
on change de mec me change de tout un
groupe c'est un truc que j'ai tourné
hier et après on revient ici il faut
parle de santo des vaccins quand on y va
mais si moi vous parler d'un truc cool
hop je vous met bien en face les spams
auprès d'un truc cool d'une et plus je
sais pas si vous l'utilisez alors c'est
une appli qui pas sorti aujourd'hui mais
qui est vachement intéressante c'est tik
tok alors tik tok moi j'utilise depuis
pas très très longtemps et je trouve ça
assez funky parce qu'en fait vous pouvez
déjà visionner du contenu qui est assez
marrant plutôt bien fait c'est assez
original
voilà des petites vidéos très très
courte avec des trucs cochons noirs et
ça c'est vraiment intéressant et en plus
je me suis mis alors j'ai commencé à
créer doucement doucement des vidéos et
d'ailleurs je vous invite à la visite
je vous montre tout de suite celle que
j'ai fait comme ça vous me direz comment
vous la trouvez pour ma part j'en suis
qu'au début voyez j'ai posté juste une
vidéo ça commence tout doucement à
arriver est-ce que c'est mon contenu bon
je vous le mets directement en plein
écran vous verrez c'est quand même un
peu plus facile à avoir regardé où
est-ce qu'on est aujourd'hui on va
trôner ensemble c'est plutôt cool ça me
fait marrer
dites moi ce que vous en pensez ce que
vous utilisez tik tok est ce que vous
trouvez ça intéressant personnellement
soit vraiment cool d'ailleurs je vous ai
mis un lien en bas dans la description
pour à l'essayer et découvrir vous allez
voir c'est gratuit c'est marrant on fait
plein de petites découvert de petites
pépites un peu rigolo il ya peut être
cassé créatif c'est ça que j'aimais
cette plateforme c'est qu'il ya plein de
mecs qui sont hyper créatif des trucs
assez drôles alors souvent c'est assez
what the fuck
mais dans l'absolu franchement c'est
toujours assez marrant la rentrée va
éclater la voiture bon je veux pas le
voir j'ai peur de voir une voiture
éclaté çà c'est marrant avec la petite
tête pas qu'il fait c'est sur le cochon
j'adore ça me fait rire attention vous
êtes prêts et tac voilà ça c'est
complètement stupide mais a fait mourir
de rire
et puis peut-être que vous allez me
croiser comme ça en train de poster deux
trois trucs pour être franchement sympa
donc allez-y
dites moi ce que vous en pensez puis
vous pouvez télécharger c'est
franchement super rigolo
voilà la boîte samsung galaxy ya 50
alors j'aime bien ça c'est sympa que sur
la face avant et noémie le modèle de
loyer up là haut vous le voyez deux
phases de dos le a50 est resté comme ça
c'est assez joli bond blanc ça reste
très design une boîte qui n'est pas
complètement dingue lorsqu'on la voit
comme ça qui marche bien c'est un modèle
qui fabriqués au vietnam pas samsung on
retrouve au d'aubin les infos
essentielles sur ce smartphone galaxy à
50 cent vingt-huit giga de stockage
écran infiniti ou triple capteur photo
ça c'est plutôt bien
capteur d'empreinte sous l'écran ce
n'est pas ça capteurs ultrasoniques
c'est un capteur optique écran infiniti
ue de 6 à 4 pouces super amoled full hd
+ faut savoir que c'est du 2340 par 1080
pixels bonbon est fin prêt et je vais
vous montrer sa main trois caméras
l'arrière 25 + 5 plus suivre caméra
frontale de 25
la mémoire interne qui ensemble un sujet
qui est extensible grâce à un port
microsd double sim qu'elle j plus d'elle
évidemment donc ce qu'on va tout de
suite on a passé des heures au point et
demi on n'a pas tari d on va juste
ouvrir le pack samsung n'en voulait pas
essayer de faire ça pourquoi n'ai je
fais vraiment attention
non je peux faire avec un petit cutter
je suis d'accord avec ça mais bon j'ai
fait avec mes skis à voile ah bon ça
c'est quoi alors pâques
déjà il ya deux choses que vous avez la
première niveau oui vous pouvez l'ouvrir
comme ça une petite languette qui
étaient installés pour venir lever s'en
va s'en occuper
vous avez la deuxième partie qui
arrêtent arrière donc ça c'est bien
voyez on le voit en deux parties pareil
petite languette là vous venez tirez
vous sortez cette partie là samsung
ok pas mal à ça c'est original
je suppose que ça s'ouvre par le bas
parce qu'une petite en cauchemar je vais
donc le prendre
l'ouvrir voyons voir ce qu'on a à
l'intérieur j'imagine que c'est
effectivement le guide de prise en main
rapide on va voir le les garanties
exactement carte de garantie régionale
loeb gagne
ok bon rien de bien dangereux là dessus
mais ça marche on retrouve de l'autre
côté
le smartphone qu'on peut venir lever
directement la gemme booth et de
couleurs c'est vraiment très très joli
on va serait dans quelques instants à
l'intérieur on retrouve son chargeur on
a également en option câble pour venir
recharger en usb type c'est utile c'est
usb
ça c'est cool on a ici des écouteurs ça
c'est aussi bien petits écouteurs
samsung c'est bien pour téléphoner ça
évite de vous cramer la tête bon après
on est sur un smartphone qui un das de
1,39 fois par kg mais dans l'absolu je
recommande quand même l'utilisation de
kits comme ça qui vient se charger qu'il
ya se brancher directement vous le voyez
là c'est une prise jack
donc ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
différentes tailles pour vie réglée
dimension de vos oreilles et ici votre
petit pic pour venir éjecté votre qu'un
film donc ça c'est plutôt cool
c'est toujours un moment un peu
religieux de dire ouvrir son smartphone
comme ça attention voilà
ouais franchement alors je sais pas ce
que vous vous en pensez mais moi j'adore
vraiment le travail qui est fait au
niveau de cette couleur bleue je la
trouve vraiment très très très belle
excellent choix fait par samsung là
dessus très beau dos il n'y a pas de
capteur d'empreinte digitale au dos donc
ça c'est plutôt bien vous avez là le
branding la marque samsung ici triple
capteur photo alors je vous le disais
vous avez un capteur principal qui doit
être juste ici à mon avis au milieu
c'est le capteur de 25 méga pixels qui
ouvre à f 1.7 vous avez le 8 méga pixels
ça doit être celui ci c'est un grand
angle qui ouvre à f 2.2 et puis celui en
haussé de 5 mégapixels pour la
profondeur de champ qui ouvre également
à f 2.2 alors à l'avant vous avez ici
une petite caméra de cette fille 25
mégapixels un écran infiniti view
infiniti ou parce que ça vous fait un
petit qu ici vous voyez au niveau 2 de
la caméra avant vous avez le haut
parleur pour écouter vos conversations
qui juste là sur la tranche qu'avons
nous on a un bouton de volume on a le
bouton pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre
on a du plastique pour l'instant que
j'ai toujours pas enlevé et qui n'est
pas très beau voilà qu'on va venir
enlevés en même temps on a un chien haut
parleur mono recharge en usb type c'est
la prise jack et qui est juste là les
petits bouts de scotch up qui viennent
le protéger et je m'en mets plein les
doigts
vous avez donc ici votre tiroir de
cartes sim avec votre extension carte
micro sd qui vient voir est surcoté ya
ya pas grand chose et ici vous avez
trouvé votre petit trou qui correspond
au micro supérieur qui vient en
réduction de bruit par rapport au micro
inférieur qui ici juste à côté de vos
haut-parleurs prise en main je trouve
bien franchement alors moi j'ai pas des
très grosses paluches
néanmoins je tiens bien dans ma main
plutôt bien pour bosser à une
why not alors après que j'aime toujours
là dessus pour moi sur sl prendra demain
elle vient chercher un peu plus haut à
une main vous avez toute la partie du
bas pour avoir la partie dioffo quand
même venir tenir un deuxième main ça
peut vous éviter un petit peu les
problèmes on les allume comme ça hop
petite vibration galaxie à 50 j'adore
voilà la bête je vous ai passé les
étapes de configuration un peu
fastidieuse pour arriver up bonjour
arriver directement ici sur le
smartphone alors est-ce qu'on est en
luminosité maximale les six mois
regarder non on va le pousser à fond
ouais il est franchement très très
lumineux alors son écran vous savez que
ça me saoule maîtrise vraiment vraiment
vraiment les écrans vous avez un écran
super amoled
ce que je vous disais c'est l'infini
tillou de par le petit us vous retrouver
ici au niveau de l'avant alors vous avez
quand même un petit manteau en bas alors
c'est très malin c'est très très bien
fait au niveau du design voyez qu'on a
foncé en bas pour que le menton se
disent paraissent un peu et puis se
fonde un peu dans la décoration
on le voit un petit peu bon on est sur
un smartphone milieu de gamme on va pas
trop trop non plus venir lui en demander
s'il avait le 4 pouces comme je vous le
disais 2340 par 1080 pixels
ça marche plutôt bien vous avez à
l'intérieur un exynos 6916 si giga de
ram
on est sur un soc milieu de gamme on est
sur un smartphone milieu de gamme vous
en douterez ici on cherche pas la
puissance ici ce qu'on va vraiment venir
rechercher c'est le smartphone un peu
passe partout avec lequel vous allez
faire pas mal de choses avec une
excellente qualité au niveau de l'écran
c'est vraiment la chose combien vous
recherchez c'est le savoir-faire de
samsung ses tripes le module photo c'est
pas la bête de compact c'est pas le
smartphone avec lequel vous allez faire
tourner les jeux les plus gourmands vous
allez faire le plus de multitâche c'est
le smartphone qui marche bien qui est
fonctionnel et c'est à dire ce qu ont
vérifié dans quelques jours lors du test
donc je vous invite dès maintenant à
vous abonner comme ça vous saurez tout
l'autonomie on va la mesure également
dans quelques jours on a une batterie de
4000 millan paire eur ça peut être
plutôt pas mal avec de la recharge en
usb type c à voir également
ça donnera en termes d'usagé dans le
temps si c'est bien oui ou non alors il
ya pas mal de choix dans ce smartphone
le fait d'avoir un double signe c'est
plutôt bien le nfc pour le paiement
dématérialisé pour les pass navigo pour
pas mal de choses ça c'est aussi assez
intéressant il a également du bluetooth
5.0 maintenant petit regret il n'a pas
de certification ip il n'est pas
certifié pour la résistance à l'eau et à
la poussière alors rassurez vous si vous
êtes dans la rue qui se met à pleuvoir
ne vous cachez pas tout de suite il
planté soyez tranquille vous êtes
vraiment rassuré là dessus néanmoins
c'est vrai qu'on aurait pu aimer avoir
une certification lors le fait d'avoir
des certifications ça coûte relativement
cher est ce que c'est pour ça que
samsung n'a pas fait certifier ce modèle
allez savoir maintenant ce qui est pas
mal là dessus c'est le 14 empreintes
digitales qui est situé juste là sous
l'écran c'est un capteur optique alors
tendez faut laisser plus longtemps ça
marche alors c'est un capteur optique ça
n'ira pas aussi vite que le capteurs
ultrasoniques on assemble les galaxy s
10 et se disent plus alors ce qu'il faut
savoir là dessus ce qui est assez
intéressant c'est que je n'ai pas avec
des gens de sainte soulle l'autre jour
nous ont dit on a mis à jour il ya eu
une vraie mise à jour au niveau du
capteur ultrasonique du s10 donc
maintenant il va beaucoup plus vite sans
que j'habite un petit peu déçu je trouve
qu'il allait pas vraiment vraiment vite
mais là dessus c'est tout autre chose là
dessus c'est un capteur optique c'est à
dire qu'il va émettre de la lumière que
les six voiliers il émet de la lumière
pour venir reconnaît votre empreinte
digitale donc je pose le doigt je
recouvre bien la surface j'attends il
déverrouille ça va un peu moins vite que
les capteurs vous aviez au dos ou sur la
tranche
mais ça a le mérite de marché et puis
surtout ça vous évite d'aller gratouille
avec votre doigt derrière vous posez
votre doigt ici devant vous couvrez bien
ça se déverrouille on s'en arrête là
aujourd'hui pour semaine boxing on va
pas aller guère plus on va pas le tester
tout ce qu'on garde ça pour dans
quelques jours donc je vous invite dès
maintenant à vous abonner si ce n'est
pas déjà le cas comme ça vous saurez
tout sur ce smartphone moi je trouve
vraiment intéressant ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est la proposition de
valeur vous avez derrière on est sur du
smartphone milieu de gamme on est sur le
milieu de la gamme à à 50 on va du à 10o
à 80 s qui auront à 90 plus tard on
verra on voit que la gamme s étoffe
combats par dizaines
ça va être vraiment intéressant je pense
qu'on regarde très très très très belle
sur cette année du côté de chez samsung
une gamme qui se réinvente pour faire un
petit peu face à la concurrence chinoise
qui est de plus en plus difficile plus
en plus agressive et là ils ont sorti un
smartphone tout cas qui est très beau
moi j'adore ce dos je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez vous est ce que vous
aimez aussi cette proposition moi je
trouve vraiment bien la couleur elle est
superbe
vraiment magnifique l'écran infiniti you
c'est pas la grosse nouveauté néanmoins
ça les rites de marché capteur
d'empreintes digitales
c'est la même chose en terme de
performances malotru qui va être à mon
avis honnête connaissant en tout cas ce
type de machine je pense pas être
surpris mais je pense quand même que ça
va être un bel appareil est maintenant
la surprise savoir et moi est du côté
des caméras et soyez seul dans quelques
jours je vous dirai tout je vous invite
donc aujourd'hui dès maintenant à me
dire comment vous trouvez est ce que
vous trouvez intéressant oui non est ce
que vous aimez cette nouvelle gamme à
est ce que vous trouvez ça intéressant
la proposition que fait samsung en 2019
pour cette gamme a vu et a marqué tout
ça bien évidemment en bas en commentaire
c'est un projet vous trouvez à 349 euros
moi je trouve intéressant plutôt bien
honnête au niveau du tarif dites moi ce
que vous en pensez s'il vous intéresse
vous a mis un lien en bas dans la
description
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on
rase nous donne rendez vous dès demain
ciao